hey Ron I'm a sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen today I wanted to rant on
something that's been bothering me for a
really long time and I've alluded to
this in previous videos but I just can't
like hold it in anymore so I want to
talk about how strange the whole eating
challenges and look bang trend is here
on YouTube so first of all what is a
mukbang well I did a little bit of
research because I'm kind of a geek like
that and apparently this comes from the
Korean word milk ja which means let's
eat and bang song which means to
broadcast please excuse my terrible
pronunciations I'm trying but I'm really
struggling and I guess that kind of
makes sense in today's eating
environment where statistics show that
50% of breakfasts are consumed alone 45%
of lunches and 25% of our dinners so
yeah I'm not really surprised that
people find comfort in watching other
people eat I'm a huge supporter of the
social power of food and eating together
as a way to kind of build community and
build relationships however I don't
really see a whole lot of harm in
watching other people eat if that is
what makes your meal feel whole there's
also the consideration that watching
other people slurp or sip or gulp
satisfies people's ASMR needs which
stands for autonomous sensory meridian
response it's not really my thing
honestly I kind of makes me cringe and I
know my husband would totally want to
divorce me if that's what I was into but
if you know that works for you and I do
not judge what I do have issue with is
that North American youtubers have
appropriated this concept of milk bang
to no longer be about companionship but
rather to be these over-the-top
sensationalized eating challenges that
in my kind of clinical settings and
circles would constitute disordered
eating why is this normal now honestly
like binge eating disorder is an actual
mental health disorder and I have to say
it this YouTube trend is like fully
glorifying it it's not cool ok so let's
talk about binge eating disorder so the
dsm-5 defines
eating disorder that's consuming in a
specific amount of time a specific
amount of food that is definitely larger
than what somebody would otherwise
consume in similar circumstances in a
similar time period now I know a lot of
you guys are probably gonna try to
defend your favorite milk bangers that's
having a really fast metabolism or
working out really hard or maybe even
clean most of time so that they can
afford their cheat meal but unless you
Michael Phelps you probably don't need
10,000 calories in one sitting and even
if you did you don't need to consume all
said 10,000 calories in pizza wings
fries and other kind of highly processed
foods that are really stark departure
from your usual diet like by all means
have wings and pizza and fries but like
you can pepper them into your normal
usual diet you don't have to eat them
all in one go it's actually quite
possible that this restrict binge
repente repeat cycle is like part of
these youtubers daily dietary regime but
they're able to maintain their body
weight and size as a result of punishing
restriction over exercising and other
dietary measures that are put in place
to help counteract these large amounts
of food so I just want to reiterate that
even if these youtubers don't gain
weight as a result of these occasional
kind of look bangs or eating stunts it
doesn't mean it's okay or healthy non
the long-term short-term or from mental
or physical health I also really hate
the term cheat day because it assigns
this moral value to food that the dieter
has decided is bad when had they just
enjoyed these foods in mindful moderate
portions regularly there wouldn't have
been this need to go overboard with the
moral transgressions you can cheat on
your spouse and you can like cheat on
your hairdresser but you can't cheat on
food so we really need to shift the
conversation and stop this disorderly
talk around food but also like don't
cheat on your spouse ok so why are we
doing this honestly I don't really know
one thing I can say from my own
experience is that I kind of think a lot
of these wellness youtubers partake in
these kind of big cheat meals or
look bangs or eating challenges as a way
to prove to the public that they don't
have an eating disorder when in my eyes
as a registered dietitian I actually
think it does the opposite I want to
make it clear that I am NOT diagnosing
these people however from my clinical
experience I can tell you that the very
act of binging is disorderly and
dangerous and triggering even if it
doesn't result in physical changes to
one's body this is not a normal way to
eat you know I was listening to this
really awesome podcast it's called
intuitive bytes definitely check it out
and they were talking about this idea of
the good fatty and that somebody in a
larger body often feels shamed and guilt
for even occasionally choosing a
quote-unquote bad food whereas the thin
youtuber gets praised for eating 10,000
calories in a single setting and clearly
blatantly blowing past their hunger and
fullness cues so because a lot of these
book bangers are generally thin fit
often promoting some kind of restrictive
diet and wellness lifestyle on their
channel their celebrated in the context
of their fitness so it's like it doesn't
even matter what they ate during their
cheat day the fact is that they look
good and their appearance tends to
overshadow they're obviously problematic
behaviors I know I talked about this in
my intuitive eating video where I kind
of gave a little bit of a brief overview
on haze or health every size but I
really want to just reiterate that we
cannot judge a book by its cover when it
comes to their health and wellness this
is a huge problem because you know a lot
of the youtubers that I review or that
I've just kind of washed their videos on
my own tend to exhibit a lot of the
symptoms of orthorexia despite looking
healthy by society standards I know
because I was one of them and I know
that they sound and talk a lot like I
did when I was at my worst and yet that
kind of behavior was perpetuated like
people complimenting me on my shrinking
body and my willpower this also kind of
reminds me of the typical fairy tale
female narrative
that really involves the false belief
that the most attractive kind of woman
is a woman who eats like she doesn't
give up and yes she looks like she
starves herself I did actually some
research on this when I did my master's
degree and I was looking specifically at
female protagonists and how they eat in
a lot of popular movies and TV shows
think about it they eat burgers and
milkshakes and fries etc and they still
manage to maintain their slim girlish
figure
meanwhile the mean girl is like always
on a diet and she's cranky as just
trying to kind of manage her weight this
negative connotation of the D word is
largely why dieting has fallen out of
Vogue and has been replaced with
wellness culture guys this is the same
thing I think you're getting the picture
here but I do not think this is cute so
for the love of all that is holy
stop mukbangs stop with the eating
challenges stop with the extreme cheat
days these are not entertaining they are
not hot they're mainly just a gross
representation of disordered eating you
know it is really cute listening and
honoring your body's innate wisdom and
if you want some more great tips on how
to do that I highly suggest you follow
along in my intuitive eating a series
enlightened really so excited to bring
you guys on this journey so if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up I want to hear your thoughts on the
whole book buying or cheat day or eating
challenge trend subscribe to the channel
and I will see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]